I'm at the Florida State Capitol where
survivors of the Parkland shooting are
forcing lawmakers to talk about guns
this is scary high school students are
way too young to be exposed to gun
violence debates
[Applause]
I'm worried like Bill O'Reilly says
should we really be promoting opinions
by teenagers in an emotional state why'd
we take a bunch of high school juniors
and say that these are experts on gun
policy now they're not experts on gun
policy simply because their school was
targeted take it from this angry boy in
a suit teenagers don't know anything so
I'm sitting down with someone my age who
would agree that this conversation
should be left to us calm unemotional
adults shut the up what I'm pissed
off Wow was Florida representative
Carlos gear most Smith acting like a
child because his assault weapons ban
was just voted down look there was a way
more pressing issue on the floor the
first day back in the Florida Capitol
after 17 people were murdered in a
public school in parkland Florida the
Florida House decided that it was
important to pass legislation that
declares porn a public health risk while
students from Stillman Douglas were
sitting in the gallery were they doing
these kids a favor showing them how the
gun debate works in America which is you
don't have it in a sick twisted way yeah
they were showing them hey after Sandy
Hook we didn't give up after pulse we
actually gave even less than we gave
before and after Parkland Republican NRA
loving lawmakers still don't give up
we're in a deficit right now we just
don't have any more to give well the
reality is the students are getting
engaged and they're part of the process
now and they're not taking any BS from
anyone thank you for watching your
language Carlos but we have a problem
kids need to be seen and not heard so I
went to see a kid and not hear him for
myself we are here today
to make sure something like what
happened at my school never happens
anywhere else you're young you don't
understand politics why don't you just
get on your phone and like play panda
pop or something first of all my go-to
outfits candy crush okay we may not be
18 we may not be legal adults but we are
showing the world that we still have a
voice in that our opinions matter you
know what I think you have a fundamental
misunderstanding of how politics works I
watch a lot of cable news hey kids
here's how the legislative body digests
gun violence after a tragedy the media
forces politicians to dry swallow a bill
it's broken down by partisan vile and
then the NRA s no-nonsense lobbyists
suck out the toxins aka and the actual
changes leaving us with what Carlos
Guillermo Smith calls
I drew this myself it's very pretty you
get an A for colors not an A for content
okay Alex should stop grading me and
start worrying about his grades from the
NRA but these kids don't seem worried
and what's more they've entered the
halls of power we've been advocating for
a gun control and stricter background
checks to make sure that guns like
assault rifles don't get into the hands
of people who don't deserve them
counterpoint don't soon kill people
people kill people if people didn't have
guns to kill people my friends and
classmates
he would not have killed that many
people with a knife with any other
weapon decides I'm gonna get a t-shirt
that sort of rebuffs we're trying to say
to me right now
these kids need to stop advocating for
change and start getting a job parents
and adults are quick to say oh like get
a job support yourself okay so then we
can speak out for what we believe in I
have to listen to you I think it should
be that way
you're never talking about gun control
again
you're fine you've been quiet go to
dance class this squad of woke teens
with low key salty why are we making it
so easy for kids to get their hands on a
freaking ballet
[Applause]
that's when it hit me these so-called
emotions that I thought discredited
these kids were actually how they
tricked people into listening to them it
was a devious tactic and it even worked
on me you see it on the news you see
these horrible things when you truly
personally experienced something like
this it changes your whole perspective
on everything I was hiding in my closet
for an hour and a half not knowing I was
gonna come out alive or not
but when I was rescued and I found my
mom I gave her the biggest hug it's time
for things like this to end we're all at
school to be educated and be prepared
for the real world but how can we be
prepared for the real world if we don't
even make it there oh my god I'm sorry
I'm tearing up because I am listening
you and I'm just thinking that you're
gonna come for my guns we respect the
right to bear arms but no person's life
is less important than a gun child logic